Warner Brothers has released the second
and final trailer for The Joker origin
story like the first teaser it contains
references to both the villains
pop-culture past and some classic movies
that inspire this gritty retelling
here's everything you might have missed
the movie is set in a Gotham City model
after early 1980s New York this is
around the same setting as to Martin
Scorsese movies that heavily influenced
Joker 1976 is taxi driver and 1983 is
the king of comedy during the scene
where Arthur flex speaks with a social
worker he says this could be a callback
to a scene from taxi driver in which
Travis Bickle played by Robert De Niro
says more of his social worker later
both Arthur and Travis are insomniacs
and these shots of them shirtless with
back injuries are strikingly similar
and speaking of Robert De Niro we get
another glimpse of him here DeNiro
police talk show host Murray Franklin
the character is incredibly similar to
the character of Jerry Langford from the
King of Comedy a movie in which a man
named Rupert Pupkin whose desperate to
be a comedian kidnaps a talk-show host
that comedian was played by none other
than Robert De Niro there are also
plenty of visual references to the king
of comedy flick watches Murray
Franklin's show from a hospital and sees
a clip of himself on it this mirrors a
scene where pumpkin watches his big
debut from a TV in a bar while pumpkins
performance is a huge success
it looks like Fleck gets humiliated in
front of the whole world and what we see
Fleck watching there isn't his actual
debut on Murray show it's a video of him
performing stand-up at a comedy club
which we also saw in the first trailer
later we see Fleck and Joker makeup
backstage Fleck tells Murray this when
you bring me out can you introduce me as
Joker before Pupkin goes live on
Langford show he says something very
similar now this is my introduction and
I like mr. Randall if he could speak it
word for word along with the movie
references there of course plenty of
references to Batman mythology Arthur's
social worker is named Deborah Kane
Deborah Kane is also a social worker in
the comic Batman the ultimate evil
the name Kane pops up throughout the
Batman stories and is actually derived
from Bob Kane who co-created the
character of Batman in one shot we see
Fleck running down a hallway with a
folder this is likely Arkham
which we saw sign for in the first
teaser Thomas Wayne Bruce Wayne's father
also pops up just a joke to you in the
same shot Wayne appears dressed up in a
tuxedo could this be the fateful night
when Bruce Wayne's parents are murdered
the Joker is the one who kills Wayne's
parents in the 1989 version of Batman
but non 2005's Batman Begins or in the
comics however at one point in the
trailer you can see a newspaper front
page with a drawing of a clown Paris a
headline that reads latest news on the
murders is it referring to a potential
string of murders or the murders of
Thomas and Martha Wayne and to top that
all off there's a brief glimpse outside
the monarch theatre the theatre in which
the Williams attended show before their
murder the trailer also gives us some
deeper glimpses at the movie's plot
including that at one point Joker's
mother penny Fleck will end up in the
hospital for reasons still unknown we
also get more shots of the Joker's
growing cult following we see somebody
holding a sign that shaped like the
clown mask that Joker's followers wear
the violence we see suggests that this
could be a full-on rebellion you can
also spot a massive clown head here in
the background that looks similar to the
masks we also see him walk by this image
which is a real 1873 painting of the
lion tamer and it wouldn't be the Joker
without his iconic laughs which we hear
again a few times in this final trailer
was there anything we missed
let us know in the comments
[Music]